so you talk a lot about about the
importance of religion and especially
you know the Constitution being for
moral and religious people do you
foresee uh that religion returning to
the United States and if so do you think
it will be by like a Grassroots movement
or by some kind of policy change it it
will be led by the Ley I'm pretty
convinced of that uh and I I do think
that there will be a return to religion
true religion uh you know everybody has
some kind of religion that you know
ultimately all politics is theological
but I mean even a return to something
approximating True Religion the reason
for this is that fashionable atheism of
the mid 20000s has been revealed as
nothing more than a publishing
phenomenon it was so weak uh as Alvin oh
there we go we' got some of my friends
back hello I wonder if they're if
they're uh religious or atheistic or
well I might not have the chance to chat
with them I think it was Alvin plantinga
the calvinist philosopher at the C
Catholic College who uh said that the
the new new atheists of the 2000s were
much less impressive than the old
atheists who tried to make an argument
for it but there's no good argument for
atheism I think that that fad has passed
and the fashional materialism the the
kind of apathy toward deeper questions
that typify Gen X and the Millennials I
think that's gone and when when I when I
travel around the country I go all over
this great country uh sometimes I travel
on holy days of obligation or on Sundays
and I I go to plenty of churches and I
notice when I go to the traditional
churches the median age is like eight
because of all the kids but even if you
take the kids out of it the median AG is
about 24 and they've all got 10 kids
somehow I don't know how and uh you know
it it's packed to the gills uh even more
so than the the more liberal worldly
churches and parishes so I I'm I know
I'm a conservative and I have to say
that the sky is constantly falling and
everything's going to pot but but on on
that bit I see a glimmer of hope which
which is good because hope is a
theological virtue and a demand made of
us by God thank you so much for coming
to speak today though I don't always
agree with you I did find this talk very
interesting because it made me reframe
this topic I don't still agree with you
but I think that's I'm thankful for that
so wanted to put that out there um first
of all do you believe Christianity is
inherently better than the other
abrahamic religions and if you do why
well I'm a Christian so of course I
believe in Christianity and in as much
as a religion contradicts Christianity I
don't believe in that religion uh so a
brief uh explanation for the hope that
lives within me I suppose is I believe
that uh Jesus Christ is who he says he
is I believe uh in God the Father
Almighty maker of heaven and Earth and
in Jesus Christ his only son our Lord I
believe that he was uh begotten of the
of the Holy Spirit born of the Virgin
Mary he became man the second person of
the Holy Trinity uh dwelt Among Us lived
uh was crucified died and was buried
heroded hell and redeemed mankind I I
think he was resurrected on on the third
day this would be one sign of that I
think there 500 W eyewitnesses to the
resurrection I think the apostles all
went off uh to the various corners of
the earth most of them to be killed I
don't think they would have done that
for uh a joke I don't think they would
have done that because they were all
just totally crazy I don't think they
were all mistaken I just think the
evidence is very strong and uh so CS
Lewis has a a little um trick which is
he says that Christ can be Lord liar or
lunatic and uh when you encounter him in
the text and in the sacred tradition he
doesn't seem like a lunatic uh when you
encounter him he doesn't seem like a
liar he seems quite truthful and uh we
have faculties of reason to to separate
truth from falsehood and uh so then it
would seem that he would have to be Lord
a Jewish friend of mine suggested a
fourth L which is that he could be a
legend but I I just don't think that's
true because one the gospel accounts
were written very shortly after the uh
crucifixion you know with within uh
living memory um the rest of the New
Testament too a lot you know some of the
Epistles were written even more earlier
on uh but then furthermore you have
non-Christian historians attesting to
this and then you just have the rid
spread of the faith uh and and to say
nothing of the many miracles that have
occurred throughout the the Millennia
and uh then then a final bit I'll take
from hir belloc because I you know I
specifically am Catholic maal snapping
papist and some people look to all the
terrible crazy things that have happened
in the Catholic church and they say why
why would you want to be part of that
how could you possibly think that's
really the church and haer bellock said
that he has to take it as a matter of
faith that the Catholic church is really
divinely instituted but one evidence for
the non-believer of its Divine
institution is that no other
organization conducted with such navish
imbecility would have lasted a
fortnite can I just quickly so I
understand why you would believe
Christianity but it sounded like you
made the claim that there was something
inherently better about Christian
doctrine than say Islamic Doctrine maybe
we can go there yes I think that it's
true and so in as much as Islam
contradicts Christianity for instance
contradicting the Divinity of Christ or
for instance uh uh extolling the total
Transcendence of Allah as the Islamic
historian iban hazm would detail uh
contrary to the Christian view in which
God is identified with the logos the
Divine logic of the universe in as much
as there are those um
uh disagreements then I would hold that
Christianity is true and therefore a a
superior religion if you're going to
practice one so do you believe then that
Judaism and Islam are inferior by any
other nature just by the fact that there
it's contradicting that's your only
contention of of course the way to uh
judge a religion is whether it's true or
not so you know religion is is just a uh
Habit of virtue that inclines the will
to give to God what he deserves so you
know it's it's not like I would say uh
I'm not Jewish cuz I don't like their
hats in fact I love their hats and I
want a shal I think they're very cool
they're expensive but they're Nic
looking hats it's not that I I say you
know I uh wouldn't be a Muslim because I
don't like the food or something the
food is very nice it's just merely a
question of which I think is most
persuasive and which I think is true and
so that would be the the Criterion for
the superiority of of one theological
viewer or another I agree with you that
Conquest could be righteous right we
just disagree on the religion part you
know that's fine my question is the
abrahamic God clearly commands us not to
kill innocent people and it says it's a
vicious evil act and it happens to be
that settlers now and historically have
actually killed innocent people I mean
that's historically a confirmed fact by
every scholar so how do you justify that
as a Christian I I would justify it
according to just War which is a concept
that goes back to Pagan antiquity and
then is developed beautifully within the
church St Augustine and St Thomas
aquinus in particular and then is
developed you know even later after the
school men and by uh non-catholics and
all all sorts of uh rational people and
there are two aspects of just War there
is uh the question of Justice in going
to war and then there's the question of
Justice in conducting war and there are
all sorts of criteria for that to your
point yes
Wars inevitably in entail uh the death
of Innocence as so does that mean that
war is never Justified no war is
sometimes Justified but there are
criteria by which the war must be
justified uh half a dozen of which one
one could recite uh you know for each
case so I you know I know that that's
not a a really zingy answer that you
could write in one bullet point on the
back of a napkin but as a priest friend
of mine once pointed out shallows are
clear and shallow thinking is clear and
profound things are a little murkier and
muddier I I don't think there are very
many pacifists in this room I don't
think pacifism is morally persuasive in
any way I don't think that there's
anything particularly good or moral
about letting the cruel rape the Earth
for instance so uh you know if if we're
recognizing that there would be some
instance in which a war would be
justified then we need to probe that
matter further and U in the case of
Conquest some conquests can be justified
some are less easily Justified it is why
in my talk I distinguished between some
of the indigenous conquests which were
either uh purely for land and plunder or
Worse to sacrifice virgins to demons and
things like that and other kinds of
conquests which were Justified for
higher higher purposes for instance
hernand Cortez conquering those demon
worshipping human sacrificing Aztecs
that would seem to be a rather Justified
Conquest especially to spread the faith
uh so uh you know the the particularity
here I think is is what really matters
um this is not to ever justify the
killing of Innocents but war is a messy
thing and it's why for thousands of
years now the brightest Minds have have
Set uh limitations around
it so people do encourage sin when they
kill innocent people even though if the
conflict large not necessarily if one is
engaging in a just war and one is not
intending to kill an innocent person if
one is not if one is has a proportional
response if one is going to war for a
good cause if one has the right
motivations if you know you can go down
the list of of uh of
justifications uh then one would not
necessarily incur a sin for that it's
certainly a sin to commit murder but
that's why we're we're uh drawing a
distinction here between a murder and a
killing in a just War I had a question
more around your around atheism so the
noted atheist um Christopher Hitchin
said morality does not come from
religion it comes from humanism and it's
stolen by religion for its own purposes
and I wonder what you think about that
quote uh not very much I guess is what I
think about it uh I I would be curious
as to what his argument is does he draw
his argument from some ancient atheist
Society maybe we call it um ritian or
something you know and it's where all
the ancient atheists lived before the
development of that awful religion
totally changed the course of human
history I I don't see that uh because
all societies have some kind of
religious Foundation because even when
we're just discussing practical
political matters those rest on moral
considerations and moral considerations
rest on epistemological considerations
you know how we can know anything at all
and epistemological considerations rest
on anthropological considerations what
is man how are we possibly to know
anything anthropological considerations
rest on ontological considerations what
does it even mean to be and ontological
considerations ultimately rest upon
theological questions what is what is
being anyway uh so you can't escape it
and the atheists can't escape it which
is why Christopher Hitchin spent all of
his latter years debating religious
people I saw uh Christopher Hitchens at
the 92nd Street y once debate Rabbi
schmoly Bic and schmoly was right schy
should have won the debate but uh
Christopher Hitchens was a little faster
and has that fun accent so he seemed to
win the debate and I think that's what a
lot of the uh atheists did in the mid
2000s but even to that quote you just
read I I don't even know how to engage
with it because I don't know what the
argument is you know he's just saying I
don't like religion basically so I think
if I'm not mistaken he's basing his
theory on the Hoban state of nature
which he believes everything derives
from there and then you put laws morals
and ethics on top of that which don't
necessarily have to come from religion
itself sure I mean if my Grandma had
Wheels she'd be a wagon I guess if we're
going to accept ridiculous premises but
by the way Hobbs too for you know I'm
not the biggest Hobbs man in the world
he's the the grandfather of liberalism
if John Lock is the father of liberalism
Hobbs is sort of the grandfather of
liberalism but he he was very confused
about a lot of things politically and
religiously but even Hobbs I don't think
would have called himself an atheist you
know I think Hitchens is being a little
uh generous he definitely wasn't an
atheist I just think the principles that
he stood for about the state of nature
and then evolving from there you don't
NE I I think he was a religious man I
think in fact he supported the king in
in correlation with like religion and
state but just the principles of do you
necessarily need religion for a society
to function he I I would say he you need
you need religion for I mean to put it
put Christopher Hitchens aside because
you're clearly a much more thoughtful
and intelligent person than the late
Christopher Hitchens uh you know
rip
uh they say don't speak ill of the dead
so I'll say a prayer for him later on I
feel sort of bad um morality requires
religion because morality refers to the
moral law and the moral law must have a
moral lawgiver and if the best answer
that the atheists can muster is that
well it's just something the humans made
up then there's no morality then it's
just a fiction it's a kind of noble lie
According to which we all live but if
it's a fiction and we all become aware
that it's a fiction then it SE to exist
just to preface my question I think we
are going to have a bit of a fundamental
disagreement uh here which which is okay
and I think that's honestly what our
country is all about um but there's been
a lot of discussion uh tonight about
sort of reigniting the flame of our
founding fathers that they attempted to
instill in us back in 1776 so i' just
like to direct our attention to
something that Thomas Jefferson spoke of
he referred to the First Amendment as a
necessary wall of separation of church
and state Jefferson himself was a
religious man but he truly believed in
the separation of church and state so
that's sort of where I fall in the issue
so I would just love to hear your
response to that sure so do you know
where that line comes
from so the line comes from a a private
letter of Thomas Jefferson it is one of
two lines ever cited by the uh
secularists for keeping religion out of
public life the other one is a line
where they say that America was in no
way founded on the Christian religion so
said John Adams except John Adams never
said that it was a line that was
negotiated by a Jeffersonian Diplomat it
was in the Treaty of Tripoli it was a
throwaway line to get the Muslim Pirates
to stop capturing our Sailors uh none of
that appears in the Constitution none of
that appears in The Federalist Papers
doesn't appear in the Declaration of
Independence it doesn't appear in any of
the serious documents and writings of
the founding fathers uh Thomas Jefferson
was probably the most liberal prominent
founding father and he gets one line in
one private letter it that view simply
did not have the force of law or public
support at the founding of our country
or at basically any time in our in our
country's history contrary to what
modern liberals would have you believe
not only does the First Amendment not
kick religion out of public life it
doesn't even prohibit the establishment
of a state Church the re the reason that
the First Amendment Establishment Clause
prohibits a church established at the
national level is because there already
were established churches at the state
level that went on unmolested for
decades in our proclamations even from
the religiously slightly wobbly founding
fathers men like uh Benjamin Franklin
they all gave thanks to God John Adams
made clear that the morality also in a
private letter that the morality for
America ought to be the Christian
morality that that was the one suited to
it John Jay gave great thanks that we
were a Christian Nation of of practicing
Christians Who had who had a long
history with one another we have in God
we trust on our currency it's in our
national anthem actually in the not very
often sung fifth verse verse uh the the
national anthem goes uh and thus be it
ever where free men shall
stand uh between our loved home and the
something
consolation H I'm going to forget some
of the words but anyway the upshot of it
is uh and thus be our motto in God is
our trust that's in the national anthem
uh it would seem to me that the pro-
religion in public life side has has the
winning argument here now in recent
decades unfortunately the secularists
have taken a little bit of a win
especially in some Court decisions since
the
1990s really going back even to the
middle of the 20th century when the
Supreme Court discovered somewhere an
invisible Inc in the Constitution that
you can't teach the Bible in schools
most important book ever written even if
you're an atheist that's the one we're
not allowed to teach you can teach
gender queer in schools but you can't
teach the Bible um and then another
decision that said that you can't pray
in schools again this was created out of
whole cloth by middle 20th century
liberals uh so that's the direction that
the country has gone in and I I suppose
I would just ask do you think that uh
the the fruit of that has been good do
you think the country is in a better
place now than we were around the time
of the founding or you know all things
considered in other parts in our history
or do you think that we're now so
confused we don't even know the
difference between a man and a woman I
mean I I do think there are myor factors
I think we can all agree the direction
the country's going in is not
necessarily good I think I would point
to different factors such as immense
polarization which I don't think
necessarily correlate to religion you
sure I I person J certainly thought it
did no I think there are people that who
which I don't disagree with people whose
moral compasses are Guided by religion
which I think is not a fundamentally bad
thing at all um but this is my point I I
do just think we're going to
fundamentally disagree I and I do
believe in secularism and I believe in
everybody's right to practice their own
religion and have it shape them as a
person I just don't think it has a place
in government personally um how how does
one believe in secularism well
personally I think it comes from my own
beliefs of I'm not I would describe
myself more as agnostic I'm not entirely
sure I was raised Jewish I was bar
mitzvot um but my belief system has sort
of been crafted by not really claiming
an understanding I do believe in science
and I'm I would think I would be a fool
to deny like unequivocably the existence
of a God because I'm not sure um but I
think I was just like you in school man
I hate I don't say that to students a
lot because it sounds very condescending
but I was just like you I was an atheist
for 10 years and I had a slight
epistemic humility which as you do which
I think was very helpful the notion that
well perhaps you know uh I don't know
for certain and then it occurred to me
that like every smart person ever in the
history of the world has believed in God
and they've all believed in roughly the
same conception of a God you know uh
some closer than others and it occurred
to me that there's more to life than
just matter and the reason I even
phrased the question as I did is because
the very notion of belief would seem to
speak to something deeper than just
fleshiness and when we start speaking
about the metaphysical world then I
think a lot of the arguments for atheism
just totally collapse and I think
probably you're going to end up as a
rather religious person if I were a
Gambling Man disagree with you most of
the time but I just wanted to push um
you on just one thing so we have this
million questions I could ask you right
colonialism all these other things but I
think specifically just about where
we're going in this country today I
think there's a very important
conversation to be had about the
founding so I I think a lot of
conservatives have this idea right of
the founders being this very religious
group of people who like you just
mentioned founded this country with very
good intentions um trying to raise it up
as the city on a hill an example for all
the world to follow and there's that
question of the religiosity but you know
we have very good evidence that um our
first President George Washington for
example was a Freemason um Thomas
Jefferson had a copy of the Bible in
which he removed every single word of
God he mentioned Miracles he was a
um John Adams uh was a unarian you being
a traditional catholic I'm sure you
would very much disagree with someone
who denies the Trinity um the mention of
that comment before about how In God We
Trust is in our coinage right this
wasn't added uh until 1950 in order to
contextualize that we were in the middle
of the Cold War The Motto predates it
but it wasn't added until yeah it
predates it because it uh was coming
from the Civil War but that was
basically to separate us from a very
atheistic Soviet Union um
I'm definitely very much in the middle
but I don't think that the libs um as
many call them are wrong to just kind of
identify that hey maybe we need to
identify a more clear picture of the
founding if we're going to talk about
how great Thomas Jefferson was and how
he wrote These very illustrious and
Noble words let's also include the fact
that he owned these slaves let's also
include the fact that he was a very
hypocritical men these were men not gods
they were flawed and I don't think that
it's a crazy idea just to point that out
and just to us establish that that's
where I'm coming from but I'd like to
know your thoughts on it your first
point was better than your second point
but they're all very good and you
obviously know what you're talking
about ironically I think you're making a
more conservative point and I might be
making a more Progressive point which is
namely I don't think that we need to
return to the founding I'm not saying we
need to get in a a time machine and go
back to 1776 I wouldn't like to do that
it's not possible to do that you can
never go backwards I also uh in response
to all of your totally factual
statements about the founders I suppose
my response would be yeah they weren't
perfect you know we would have we would
have major disagreements over religion
though in the case of Thomas Jefferson
frankly the man forgot more about
religion than most people ever learn
today so this was also a group of
extraordinarily educated people who did
go a bit wrong on a number of questions
absolutely of course I don't want to go
back to that they weren't perfect the
reason that I would refrain from harping
constantly
over all of their personal moral
failings is because we all have them you
know look we live in a country right now
that kills 800,000 babies a year and I
know there are people who support
abortion future Generations will look on
that with horror in the same way that we
look on the Aztec of Teno tlon I just I
promise you that and so I would like us
to be given a little bit of Grace as
well and the founding fathers had all
sorts of moral trepidations about
slavery they wrote about them they you
know this is not some psycho Babble here
they you know you can read it in their
own words and so they were men who were
captive of their time and they they did
the best they could and in some cases
they made errors that's true I think it
it is more productive though to focus on
the philosophical and political issues
that they got wrong because as you point
out there are a lot of them but then you
point out the answer to that I think
accidentally which is you say for
instance In God We Trust was not added
to our currency until the 20th century
The Motto comes from the middle of the
19th century but it was added to our
currency later on yes that's true you
know what I call that progress I call
that an improvement and I think that but
I I'll push you on this cuz you say they
were products of their time completely
understand but with that with that way
of thinking we have this understanding
that Progressive modern ideology of
Human Rights and fairness just came out
of nowhere because there were people in
that time who also disagreed John Adams
was a founding father that I very much
respect because out of principle he
never owned a slave he believed it was
wrong so how can we say they were
products of their time when people in
that time were also criticizing the
institution well because there people in
Massachusetts had a Le less of an
economic um um need incentive and uh
capture even uh for slavery where it
just was then someone say in Virginia
like Thomas Jefferson so there's even
context Between the States you know the
colonies were were quite different we
live in a more homogenized Nation today
that was not the case the Southern
economy was largely dependent on slavery
it was practiced in the North but just
just it wasn't as Reliant um so they
they were men of their time they they
were more conscious of the errors of
their time than many of us are today of
the errors of our time uh you mention uh
the notion of human rights which is one
that I think is a little bit fuzzy
because everyone always claims a human
right to whatever it is exactly that he
wants uh but it comes from a good place
which is the notion of Human Rights
comes from the notion of natural rights
and the notion of natural rights can
sometimes get a little fuzzy too but
that comes from the notion of natural
law and that natur law is pretty solid
and so where does that come from that
doesn't come from some lib hippie in the
20th century that comes from the church
that comes from the various serious
thinkers of Western Civilization so I
think that we can identify where people
have gone uh wrong a little bit
philosophically or or where they just
made mistakes because they were
imperfect men living and doing the best
they can and we can we can try to deal
with our own battles just as I criticize
conservatives for constantly wanting to
dig up the corpse of Ronald Reagan and
just repeat the same five lines over and
over from the Gipper I say let the man
die you know he he did his part he did
his part he was a good man now we have
to fight our battles too I I think the
same thing of the founding fathers when
I refer to these great men of history
and why we ought to look up to them uh
it is in part because we would not be
here without them and so it's an
extension of filial piety just as you
ought to go a little soft on your
parents even if they're acting like
jerks sometimes so too we ought to go a
little soft on our country patriotism is
one extension of filial piety and we
ought to go soft even on our political
ancestors as well because we are
standing on the shoulders of those
giants some of us think that we're
flying but we're not and someday people
are going to correct our errors as well
and uh we should we should hope for the
same the same Grace that we might afford
to our forebears because otherwise then
we're just going to tear everybody down
and we're going to say our country was
founded by the most rotten people on the
stupidest ideas and we're all a bunch of
just bags of Flesh who have nothing but
our own personal interest and that's
going to lead us to degradation and no
one's going to flourish from that at all